saturday afternoon pennant race baseball
yeah the orioles are in a penta race how
about them
montgomery scuffled his last couple of
starts he's averaging only about
four innings per start not to say if
he's not pitching well yeah
sure you leave him in but with a fully
rested bullpen because tanaka
and cole were so good yesterday i think
boone could manage this game
aggressively in terms of going to his
bullpen but there's the change up there
to get the swing of the miss the two
aboard for pedro severino
a strikeout from a foul tip from
severino montgomery battling here in the
first
weighs at the 1-2 a strikeout for
montgomery to escape
the little first inning jam the mayhew
hammers everybody but he's
he's been especially tough on baltimore
since joining the yankees his average
now
approaching 400. oh dj hangs back
hits it well the left center field
running back is mount castle
and it's off the base of the wall lemay
who's gonna round
first and second and drops back
with a stand up double aaron hicks is
just so good at sitting on fastballs
one out walk and a walk back flip for
eric first and third now for clint
frazier
swings at the first pitch into right
field stewart drifting over coming in
and gets a glove on it that's going to
be good enough for dj lomejo to score in
the sac fly it's one nothing new york
papaleka he's really turned it around
his last 19 games
oh good morning good afternoon and good
night pat felika
one and two to rio ruiz and montgomery
is making baltimore look silly
back-to-back strikeouts
for the yankees lefty to get out of the
second montgomery
it seems like there's a different look
about him today you like his pace don't
you i
like the pace but more so how he's
executing he's getting swings and misses
and that's not his game
should be curveball down here and it is
i mean who is this guy they say you
shouldn't pitch in patterns but when the
pattern's working this well
why deviate eight swings and misses now
i mean
the orioles are swinging half the time
are missing half the time they swing the
bet
and again it's the same pattern see this
run that he's been on
only one of his outs has been recorded
on a pitch
in the strike zone he's done a great job
expanding
the zone with two strikes and
baltimore's helped him out and he did it
again just like that goes upstairs
to get mount castle strike three now
seven k's on the day
to say that this outing thus far is
encouraging to the yankees
is an understatement oh he stayed with
the change up doubled up on it and got
the swing and miss
jordan montgomery has tied his career
high eight strikeouts and we're just in
the fourth inning
top of the fifth inning went away for
rio ruiz
oh perfect placement for a strikeout of
ruiz
montgomery has set a new career high
he's got nine punches
now tying run in scoring position mount
castle to the dish
this makes it the first offering from
montgomery shallow center field hicks
jogging in but going back was
estrada he can't make the catch so
alberto comes home and we're tied
and alberto does the right thing there's
no reason to go back and tag on that
ball if it's caught you're not going
anywhere and he's far enough away from
third to be able to score in case the
ball does land
and it does aaron boone here to get just
a fresh arm to get green
on nunez i mean listen contact has been
softest inning for the most part against
jordan montgomery but the right play is
just getting a fresh arm right here now
he's not happy you can tell yeah pitcher
doesn't want to leave a game anytime
especially when they feel like they're
still throwing the ball well
and that's why booney had to grab him
and explain a little bit
one run on just three hits through 72
pitches
really encouraging stuff from him today
and aaron boone and the yankees just
hoping he can build on that next time
you see it
as this game has gone along it's become
more
important for the yankees to win this
game than the orioles and i say that
because the yankees invested a real good
start from jordan montgomery career-high
nine punch-outs
used all their winning pieces in their
bullpen in terms of green
britain and now chapman they've got a
lot invested in this game
chapman will settle in for this 3-2
to stewart strike three
the chapman stare he's having fun
oh yeah he is back-to-back punchies dj
lemay he was the first yankee now who
will get a
second look at valdez we're going to
extra innings
in the bronx
pitch gets away and that allows dj
lemayo to trot over to
third base the yankees fourth
consecutive victory
90 feet away harvey's 2-2 boy
get it in the air let's go home
lemaihue scores the yankees win 2-1
now four and a half games clearer
baltimore in the standings